all right quick fire
yeah quick fire where'd you grow up
where you from originally
um
la los angeles south central yeah
well actually mourinho valley more
likely i would say more merino valley
because most of some of my childhood i
was out there so i'm kind of familiar
with that area too
and tell me about your child i did both
your parents growing up
um well my mother is dead
um
huh when did you lose your mom um 0-9
september september 0.9 i'm sorry
yeah um
my dad
he's
he's alive but we don't associate we
don't talk to each other at all
you know he's approached me like i was a
woman on the street
like trying to physically get with me
and i'm like i'm your child how are you
gonna get with me you know how are you
going to approach me like that how are
you not going to know that this is your
child you're talking to
you know he's done some foul [ __ ]
you know he's done some real fast [ __ ]
to me so we don't talk
i just found out that i had a older
brother my whole life i thought i was
the oldest child i just found out i have
an older brother that i have ran into
he talks to my dad my younger brother
talks to my dad but i don't i'm my mom's
only child so
it really really doesn't mean nothing to
me
yeah how would you describe your
childhood
rough
confused what kind of stuff was going on
well first off
my mom was 14 when she had me
she got pregnant at 13
and
had me at 14.
my dad was 22 years old
so that started a problem straight from
the gate you know
that that started my so i came into the
world in a
troubled situation you know
so
i don't remember too much as of being a
baby a child child but you know two or
three i remember you know i never stayed
with my grandmother i don't know why
i don't even know my grandmother's last
name so who are you raised by
i was bounced between
my second cousin
who
raised me
pretty much a lot
that's the one in moreno valley um
and my
great aunt
and that was in south central los
angeles
yeah
so
yeah i was basically bounced in between
there and
both of those places you know one had me
for about two years then then i go over
to moreno valley they have me for about
two years
then i go back to los angeles they have
me for about two years they were just
basically playing ping pong
did you ever spend time with your mom
well my mom she was in the streets you
know
she had a drug problem
so she was in the streets but one thing
i can't say she would come by when i was
in los angeles she would come you know
bring me little gifts and come and see
me
come and take me like to the park or
something you know
it's hard to imagine having a 14 year
old mom
wow i mean we were 15 16 as you guys
grow up
yeah that's crazy no i was like i
remember my earliest
memory of
me and having an interaction with my mom
was
i was about i say about
six or seven i had to be about six or
seven
and um she had came to my cousin's house
to pick me up
and
you know we had our little outing you
know they never denied her coming to get
me you know
but you know she didn't have a real
place to take me she didn't have like a
house or anything so that was difficult
but we went to the park we had a little
outing
and then she said it was time for her to
take me home
and i was like no mommy i don't want to
go i want to stay with you
i'm not knowing she's staying in a car
in a
liquor store parking lot with her
boyfriend
so she didn't want to have me
in the car with her
so
she a friend of hers uh he was a drunk
name
he was a drunk um so he said that we
could
you know sleep on his floor at his house
you know overnight you know
bni
so
we go over there to sleep
and in the middle of the night he comes
and pees on us
you know he's he's drunk so he mistakes
us for the bathroom
and he peed on us
and i just remember my mom
jumping up and making that man touch
every wall in that house
because you peed on my baby
and then and then she really made me go
home she took me home you know because
she felt bad about
that situation you know
i've got
one picture of me and my mother together
and that's when she was
in a program it was a couple of days
before my birthday
and we went to the you know the one hour
photos and we took pictures
you know she gave me a
pen necklace it was you know a necklace
and on a rope with a pen on it she had
getting one of those
and
and she had on this
purple
bam bam and um
what pebbles
a sweater flintstone sweater
i love that i love that that shirt that
was my favorite little um cartoons
yeah
so yeah
that was about the earliest
i really had any interaction with my mom
but she was like i guess she was about
20 something 24 25 you know
i was eight so yeah i guess so
hey yeah she was about 20 something
yeah
in general how would you describe your
childhood
i mean you had any abuse or any
the fact that you're passed around from
caregiver to caregiver
opens up the door for
a lot of [ __ ]
yeah
well my cousin
my cousin's son
used to watch me
you know
he had a son well a stepson
you know a few years younger than me
and um
he used to um you know she would like go
to her little hobby classes or have a
doctor's appointment or something
and
he used to watch me
you know go over there go get in the
pool and you know
you know he's my cousin you know
um
you know but he uh
when
his son was like at his little his
friend's house or it was just me and him
in the house
you know back then i
didn't you know know what it
was i just knew i didn't like it
but he used to touch on me and
he
tried to put his thing in me and
have me put my mouth on his stick and
yeah
and this went on for a while
so sometimes i used to like coming
to my
aunt's house in los angeles to get away
from that situation
yeah
but that was still my answer was still
no better it wasn't like it was a better
situation you know because i was never
really treated like i belonged because i
was
a cousin you know
i wasn't you know it's my great aunt
raising me this isn't my arm raising me
it's my great aunt
you know
she's got children her children's got
children so i'm around my cousins
so it was never like
fitted in i was always felt like an
outcast like because everybody was they
were with their brothers or they were
with their uncle and aunts and
they're just my cousins you know
it's you know it was family but it
wasn't
you know
i don't know i don't know how to explain
it
it's just real [ __ ] up
but
it was it was okay
until
my mom got clean
and she
had got custody of me you know she came
in not custody because she never gave up
for rice it was just i was staying with
family so but i was living with her then
you know
and uh
i stole five dollars from her
she told me i couldn't have the five
dollars from the gate though
you know i know i was wrong
i know i was wrong
i just would have left that five dollars
alone a lot of a lot of [ __ ] probably be
a whole lot different
for real
but um
i took the five dollars to get me and my
best friend
some burger king because i was getting
bust to school so i went to school in
granada hills you know i was so i got
bus to school so we had the burger king
stand and we had the county lunch and we
had the taco bell you know in high
school you know so
i am
well junior high actually so i took the
five hours so me i could give me and my
best friend some burger king right
i didn't want catty lunch that day
ah [ __ ] but um
you got caught
no i didn't get caught well she was
gonna notice the five dollars missing
but
okay i went to school the next day spent
the five dollars
and when i came home
my mama whooped my ass i mean she
whooped my ass
she woke me with everything she could
get her hands on
she did she was mad
so
when she went to go i think to the store
or something i snuck on the phone
mind you i'm not supposed to be calling
no 818 area code i'm calling my best
friend who stays in granada hills like i
got in trouble
i got in trouble because we had burger
king
but um she left a lot of
marks on me you know to me it wasn't
you know marx it was my whooping you
know i deserved it you know
but um
me going to a predominantly white school
when i
changed for pe my friend saw the marks
on me
right plus i was having trouble sitting
because you know my mom really would but
you know
so i had to
go from
fifth period to the nurse's office
because of the marks on my body
and from there
i went to
the police station
the police came and picked me up from
the nurse's office
mind you i'm supposed to be getting on
the bus going home when the last bell
rings
they telling me
that
i got to stay there i can't get on the
bus you know
is there a number i can call
and
my cousin in merino valley she's always
had the same number ever since i was a
baby ever since i was a little kid to
this day her number is the same okay
so
that was the only number i knew by heart
so she comes and meets mind you i'm in
granada hills she comes all the way from
merino valley they meet like halfway
for her to you know pick me up
i guess they arrest my mom
i don't know what happened after that
with my mom i just know i didn't i
didn't see her no more
so
my cousin she wasn't a close enough
relative
for her to just you know get custody of
me so she had to go to the classes you
know the cpr
and the foster parent classes and all
that because i became a ward of the
court
so she did that you know it was just
like she she would basically raise me
earlier so it wasn't nothing new
so
i started
rebelling
after they took me from my mom
i started acting out mind you i'm a
ab student
i go to
cdf student
you know i start
skipping class stealing from my stealing
my teachers purses i just really started
rebelling smoking cigarettes
and just doing a whole lot of extra [ __ ]
because i was rebelling i was going
against them because i was mad they took
me from my mom the first time i got to
fight me i'm about
what
13 years old i finally get to stay with
my mom and i [ __ ] up and
they take me
and
i'm mad at the world now
because i don't feel like they should
have
i feel like okay i got a weapon okay
it's gonna heal let me go back to my mom
i was wrong i took the five dollars
it was my fault
it's not like she was just going around
beating on me
she woke me the best the only way she
knew how and i was hopping all over the
place
so i got marks all over me because i was
jumping up and down
but
of course in my school they didn't see
it that way they saw it as abuse
so from there
my cousin who went through all these
classes just to get custody of me she
doesn't
she's not able to handle it anymore
you know she's an older woman so she's
not able to handle the rebellion she
so
my mom's trying to get herself together
and so she the
bcsf's like
okay well we are going to pay her to
foster home
my mom sent me to my
another great aunt who i didn't even
know had never even met
and i started staying there
then i just it all went downhill from
there
they decided that a few months before my
mom was supposed to get
custody back before we were supposed to
go to court they decided that
they couldn't handle me anymore i think
it was because they weren't getting paid
as much as they felt as they should
and i was doing extra [ __ ] you know
getting
you know that's suspended from school
and
yeah
but um
anyways from there i went to a foster
home
my first foster home
really set the tone of my
idea towards every other foster home it
gave you a perception of what a foster
home was
and that was abusive
because
a girl
i was in a foster home and
a girl
whose bed i had took
you know
had
popped up this is on christmas eve mind
you
my mom had a visit with me and our visit
didn't go too good because she was
intoxicated so she ends up jumping on me
you know
and so my foster brother comes picks me
up
and we get to open one present
as we're
going to
go back to the house to open our present
we see the girl whose bed i have you
know who ran away from this foster home
so the lady has her get in the van so
she's going back to the house with us
you know
until after the holiday so the foster
people can come and get her or whatever
whatever however it goes
but um
it was
three of us before she came into the
house
that day
and we had all been there a different
amount of time
i was basically the newest one
so
there was one boy there
and so
the oldest girl who was my roommate
she got a hundred one dollar bills
the boy who
was in another room he got 75 one dollar
bills
and because i've been there the longest
i got 51 bills
now mind you at dinner
this girl
who we picked up
says
mind you the little incident i just had
with my mother earlier that day
so the girl says something about my
mother
so i flash on her
and so they send me to my room they get
up from the dinner table go to your room
you know
so i fall asleep
i'm getting woke up saying that
the girl's money is gone
and
where is it at it was only me in the
room
so they start searching the room they
find the girls ones mixed all throughout
my stuff in my drawer and my socks
i know i didn't sleepwalk i know i
didn't sit here and
so
the girl basically set me up and the
lady
swore up and down that i was lying that
i had stole that i took the girl's money
and she had me in a corner and she
choked me and she was a tall lady so she
had me off of my feet
choking me telling me if i don't tell
the truth but i'm like so i just agreed
with whatever she said so she would let
me go
you know
and it was just crazy
but from that foster home
all i did was
go to another foster home
and i just ran away from that one
because i wasn't gonna let that happen
to me again
and every time they caught me i just ran
away again and again and again
so
my family was never really able to keep
up with me or keep in contact with me
i don't know if they were even trying
so i just ran and ran
so
at 13
14
i had to pretend i was older
i had to
you know start prostituting
so that i could make some type of way
to do
what i had to do to be able to feed
myself to have clothes and
i end up
running across this guy
and uh
he was in his 30
he was 39 i believe and i'm like
i think i i was just 15. i was just
turning 15.
you know we got together so that was my
parent
he had three boys
and
we were sitting there
we were doing it you know
but he was abusive
when he got drunk
he
got abusive you know
so what ends up happening is
i go to
ho and gardena right i'm going in
gardena
and um
they they arrest me for intoxication
because
i had walked so hard i walked my shoes
off so hard
one of the heels on my boot was off so i
guess i was it looked like i was
stabbing but it was just that that's how
my boot was
so they taking they found a little joint
in my perk in my wallet not even as big
as my pinky nail
they took me in for intoxication
in public
so i'm calling him like you gotta hurry
up and
get me out of here before my
fingerprints come back before my
fingerprints come back because i know
when my fingerprints come back it's
gonna say i'm 60 i'm 17 years old
and i'm going to juvenile
he didn't
he didn't know that because i got
arrested in hollywood one time
and
because my prints weren't in the system
and i knew
one of my friends names i used her name
so i went through twin towers and i was
only 16.
but that's by using her name
i was working in waterworld but i had
signed her to get released on what's it
called a work release
and i never did it i was like she's
gonna have to get get her own [ __ ]
together this is what she did i didn't
do it
so
when my fingerprints come back
they take me to los pedrinos
from las paginos i'm calling my i'm
calling my pimp black
he answers the phone and it says you
have a collect call from a juvenile in
las vegas you know
he hangs off the phone click he wouldn't
answer the phone for
a while
but
one day
he answered the phone and
he was just like
you i've been with him so long that
he couldn't just leave me out there i
was doing more than what
women might there that i was
perpetrating age were doing you know
even though i was a child
you know i was helping him take care of
his kids i was going out prostituting i
was cooking you know i was going to
parent-teacher conferences knowing i
should be in that class
you know
so
he tried to get custody of me he said he
was my uncle and he was trying to get
custody of me you know
but the judge wasn't going for that it
was about three months before i turned
18 and the judge was like you're about
to do it you're in juvenile camp
but he was there for he he was there
when we got a whole year you know he
came brought me boxes wrote me sent
pictures all that you know
i got out and i just couldn't handle
the physical abuse anymore so i left
them
you know
and i just started
i was 18 out here
by myself you know nowhere to go
don't know where my family had
know where certain ones are but really
not even trying to deal with them don't
know where my mom's at don't care where
my dad's at
just out there
then
um
oh man then
so i really get into prostituting you
know for myself it's like i don't need
it that's when i start i get the idea i
don't need a i don't need a pimp you
know i gotta make my money for me
so i start going and you know i run into
someone
and
you know
that's who gave me my name
fire their name was fi their day was
fire
so
you know one day they saw me i hopped in
a car
and the car just went around the block
and by the time
it was like
47 seconds i say
by the time i came back around i was
already paid date done happy camper
ready to go
they were like that's your name i'm
gonna call you quick
quickfire yeah
so that's how i got that name
you know
but um i just really went out here
doing what i needed to do
trying to
keep my head above water
you know
and
what
i was
15.
i started
using cocaine
you smoking crack
you know
and
it's like
it made me feel like i fit in like
whoever i was around you know that's
what they were doing so
you know that's what i'm gonna do you
know
and it's always it was at first it was
just to fit in basically you know
but
then
stuff started happening like i got clean
i was in a program i've been in the
program for 47 days
and
i get a call and
it's
my
uncle on my
grandfather's side of the family
and um
he's telling me that
my mom's in the hospital
and it don't look good
so
you know
mind you
for the first time in 12 years
i had seen
finally seen my mother
in the county jail
going down to
to medical
because i have seizures and
my mother contracted hiv
out in the streets you know
she told me when i was 12 that she had
contracted hiv
so you know
that's why i'm so
adamant
on things about condoms because you know
i've been like i've been like that ever
since i was young because my mother
taught me about the risk of
unprotected sex so that's why i'm 38 no
children
you know it's not worth it
but when i saw my mom
it just shocked shocked her and i i just
started crying i hadn't seen her in 12
years
i hadn't seen her since the day she
jumped on me
on christmas i hadn't seen her since
then
here i am
25
about to get sent to a program and we're
going down to the medical clinic
together
and she was
she was so small now she she looked like
a little kid to me
you know she wasn't the big woman i saw
as a child you know
she was a little she looked fragile you
know
same day she ends up getting released
you know
she gave me a number that didn't work or
i don't know what happened but when i
end up getting out
before i end up going to a program 47
days into my sobriety
i'm getting a call telling me that she's
in the hospital and doesn't look good
i get to the hospital my mother's
already passed i'm not knowing she's
already passed
but she literally just finished taking
her breath seconds before i walked
through the door
so i'm in the elevator or the hallway
and
so i go behind the curtain and i see icu
and i'm talking to her
and the nurse just comes in and closes
her eyes
and i realize
my mom's not there no more you know
she's dead
and i'm sitting up here i just talk and
i was just talking to her thinking that
you know she could at least hear me
and
when the lady closed her eyes
one of her eyes just stayed focused on
me
it was like it wouldn't close all the
way
so i know she heard me
and it's like
a week before that
i had called
my
fam my cousin in marina valley whose
number hasn't ever changed
and she brought my grandmother with her
to see me at the rehab i hadn't seen
them in 12 years
you know a week before yeah
and what happens
i'm calling them back a week later
telling them my mom's dead
they haven't seen my mom in
years more than 12 years they haven't
seen my mom in like almost 20 years
my mom died three months after her 40th
birthday
complications of hiv
her lungs collapsed
my mom was already asthmatic
her lungs collapsed
so
when i'm out on the streets and men ask
me
do you do it no i don't do anything
bareback
no
i'm sorry it's not worth my life
and a lot of people need to really start
taking that into consideration
but
anyways
it's like
i felt like
if i got in touch with her
before
when i first got out of jail instead of
going to the program or whatever
you know maybe i could have done
something
but
everyone goes i couldn't do anything i
was where i was supposed to be because
if i wasn't there
i would have been in the streets
and i probably would have never got the
news
in the first place
but the only reason way way my family
was able to reach me was because
in the program that's where my id was
sent to that's where my social was sent
to because i've been in the program
you know
so i think i'm thankful for that
real thankful
so
yeah
that's how my childhood was
that's how my adulthood was that's
where
everything
began and answering
and
there's
stuff in my
memory
that
i know i black out because i don't know
who taught i don't remember who taught
me how to ride a bike
i don't remember how i learned how to
roll up skate rollerblade
i don't remember any of that i just know
i know how to do it i don't remember who
taught me
i've never stayed with my grandmother
and that that [ __ ] with me like
i'm her first grandchild
why have i never why wouldn't i she'd be
the first person to get custody of why
wouldn't she be the first person to want
to get custody of me right
so
that makes me feel some type of way
then it's like
why do i
have
to
deal with
a family that
couldn't even
give my mother a funeral and i mean
my family members are
retired second level
secretaries for the los angeles police
department and
retired
general managers for pacific bell
but they they going to china and africa
taking cruises
but they couldn't give my mother a
funeral
my grandfather's side of the family
gave her a memorial at least
and a car wash
that
the programs church the program that i
was in
church helped me
help me throw
the car wash is what
cremated her by the county
you know
my grandmother didn't shed a tear it's
like
that's your first child that's your
firstborn
why wouldn't you want her to have a
memorial headstone and all that
why
i got into a car with this
man who was going
on down
the street
raping girl you know cutting them and
he was perpetrating like he was a
uh paisa he had the
sombrero
[ __ ] poncho
booze
straight bumping
music you know
in a
little green green um camaro
so
i hop in the car with him we're supposed
to be going to this one motel
the motel turned
entrances
off of main street so off the main
street you turn into the motel it sits
on the corner though
so instead of pulling into the motel
he pulls it down he hits the street and
pulls into the middle of the bar pulls
over and parks i'm like um
the motel's that way you know
all of a sudden he speaks straight
perfect english
you about to
give me some [ __ ] and suck my dick and
i'm not about to give you [ __ ]
and if you got a problem with it i can
show you
now i'm just dumbfounded i'm just like i
know i didn't just jump into no car with
those but
i'm sitting there like
so
he pulls out a gun
he says oh you think i'm bullshitting it
hits me inside the head with a gun so
i'm like i'm still just really stuck i
don't know what to do
i'm just stuck
and so he says [ __ ] you think i'm
playing with you
any [ __ ] puts it to my head
and he pulls the trigger
it clicks
there's no bullet in the chamber
by the grace of god only by his grace
and i know that
when that gun clicked and i realized i
wasn't dead
we start fighting
because now i'm fighting for my life
if you were gonna if there was a bullet
in the chamber i'd just be dead right
now and you he didn't care that was his
intention he didn't care
so we're fighting
somehow
the gun gets tossed to the back seat
i've got a seat belt on
i'm trying to open the door and get out
i can't so i'm constantly you know i'm
trying to
kick everything
all of a sudden
i just feel it feels like somebody
dumped a cup of water on me i just
and i just pause just in mid fight i
just stop
and i'm covered in blood
and i look at him and i say what did you
do to me
and he opens my door unbuckles my seat
belt
and kicks me out
i'm drenched in blood he ends up
stabbing me seven
times i have permanent scars that will
never go away
ever
ever
this side of my hand is numb permanently
because he hit a main vein or something
this was like that big when i first got
it mind you this is
a few weeks before my 21st birthday
never forget it
and so the ambulance comes
and they're like you need to go to the
hospital
i'm like
i don't i don't do good with hospitals
i've had family plans in hospitals i
don't need to go to hospital i'm okay
just take me home
i was staring with this man through an
alley and all this and it was crazy
but um
[Music]
so the police took me home
and
i'm like i need some drugs
i'm wrapped up
mind you just got stabbed seven times
i need some drugs straight up i need
some drugs i i'm not trying to feel i
don't have any medication because i just
that's declined to go to the hospital so
ain't no drugs in my system ain't no
narcotics no nothing i'm sober as hell
and
the pain's starting to set in
so mind you i'm cut i have my outfit i'm
cut it's covered in blood
so i look like a walking a walking dead
person down here i'm covered in blood
and so
i end up going to this spot
taking a hit and this
cut right here
it just starts gushing out good blood
again
and
the drug dealer of the house was like
um
you know they helped clean me up and all
that and they were like if anybody gives
her a hit up in this house y'all y'all
can't come here no more
and by the grace of god
for like
a week and a half two weeks they took
care of me at the spot
changed my wounds washed me to you know
healed me up to guarantee
i'm grateful for that
[Music]
you know
that's crazy
i remember
i was in a
car accident
me and this girl that ran away from a
foster home out in redlands
we ended up getting with some pimp dude
and he took us to sunset
mind you
we're 13 14 years old i'm not knowing
that we're not knowing we're not
supposed to talk to these black dudes or
whatever so we're talking to the black
dude
and they were pimps
they had on the lawn nice cold
all that and each one of them had a girl
out there on sunset but they were they
were like brothers or best friends and
they stayed together
and each one had one hole out there and
they came in different cars but they
lived at the same place
so i get in the car with one guy
she gets in the car with the other guy
we hop on the freeway
i wake up
to my body getting thrown out of
from the back passenger
side
through the driver's side window while
the car flipped on the freeway
when i come to
i'm watching
traffic come towards me
and i i can't do anything because i've
got a fractured post and a fractured rib
i can't move
this is how i know there's a guy
a 18-wheeler literally
ends up jackknifing
and stopping the traffic on a 91 freeway
early morning
i'll never forget that
and it's crazy because where do i end up
moreno valley hospital
right back where my cousins are
but remember i'm perpetrating like i'm
older
so i make up a name
and i didn't know that older people you
know if you can't pay your bill they
kick you out to hospitals
so i'm in the hospital i can't walk
because i have a fractured pelvis
i can't move i'm literally bedridden
i've got a catheter in me
and you know they're like well um
you don't have no insurance and da da da
da we're going to have to release you
i just come clean
i'm i'm 14 years old
in the foster system and here goes the
same number once again the number that's
never changed all my life
and end up calling in
social worker ends up getting called
so
end up
going to another foster home
i just really jumped from foster home to
foster home
because i didn't trust
staying there too long
so i just was always in the streets
never really had no
sit down family
i was always
on the streets always having to
perpetrate like i was older in order for
people to accept me you know because
they wouldn't want no child around them
you know i couldn't let them know i was
a child or they'd send me back to the
foster people
so that's
that was what childhood was like
as an adult
after my mother passed
i ended up relapsing
it's just hard out there
it's hard
it's hard
you're still working
yeah
gotta
gotta keep a roof over my head gotta
keep food in my stomach did you ever
save money
i tried to save as much as i can but
i've got a car so i gotta have gas
you know and it's hard what i make
through the day
doesn't last too long you know
gotta pay for a room
buy food buy something to wear
put gas in the car oil
you know
so
save as much as i can
but that's
only to save the state stay above
do you water yeah
no none you never had kids no
no
no
i don't
i think
it's
the fact that i don't want
to bring
a child into the world
unless i know
i can give them
what they need what
they have to have
you know
the love the companionship
you know
a stable home
my thoughts were when i had a baby it
was going to be you know the white
picker fence you know
the grandmother coming to get them on
the weekends and you know
i don't even know my grandmother
and now my mother's dead it just really
just made me like
really just not want kids
it's like
why
i don't even know my grandmother so not
only would they not have a grandmother
their great-grandmother they don't even
know because i don't even know her
it's just not fair
i feel
maybe one day
hopefully
what's your biggest regret
taking that five dollars from my mama
[Music]
my biggest regret is taking out five
dollars from my mother
that's the biggest regret of my life
five dollars
[Music]
i fight out has changed my life
and finally just cost me my life
i find out this was really
not needed
i find i just cost way way more
that five dollars cost me a whole lot
more than five dollars
good light
[Applause]
tell me how this line of work has
changed over the years
well back in the days
it was more of
dates
just
really
just dating and not having any ulterior
motives you know they want to date and
go you know just handle business and go
nowadays they want to procrastinate they
want to lowball you they want to
[ __ ] around
a lot of them have no intentions of
paying a lot of them just come with
game
you know they come with a whole lot of
drama
and it's like it's more
more youngsters
trying to do
[ __ ] and even a lot of some older
cats you know [ __ ] want to rape
people
beat them beat them up take the money
back
it's like it's
it's
it's change for the worst it's like
plus there's too much competition out
there
it's it's too many there's too many
girls out there now
and now
that
it's
so many it's like
all they do is ride up and down the
street all day
you know
before okay well they got their pick of
this one this one this one this this one
it's not too many there's only a few up
and down the street
now every other corner there's a girl
you know
and since i'm getting older it don't
it really doesn't help any
younger competition
you know
yeah so that really doesn't help
yeah
yeah
yeah what do you wish you'd done
differently
in your life
i wish that
i would have stayed in that program
i wish that
i hadn't rebelled when they took me away
from my mom that i just dealt with it
and
didn't go
so
negative
because my mother was doing everything
she could to get me back when she
finally did get clean
she had got her an apartment
she had got married
you know she was doing everything she
could to get one
but it was like i was working against
her because i wasn't
i wasn't doing anything good i was
just
being a badass kid
but it was like before when i was good
they took me her
so i thought maybe me acting up
they'd give me back to her you know
don't nobody want a bad kid give her
back to her mama that was my that was my
train of thought
because the whole time i was good they
kept me from her
so
it all boils back down to that five
dollars
it really does
all goes down to that five dollars
you been in love before
i thought i
have i thought i had
but it's like
the love that i get
is like
it's not really love it seems it seems
like it's you know
you it's usefulness you know
they use me today they find a more need
for me or they find a better something
better you know it's like
it's not really love there
but i think i found love i think i
think i have
i think i have
you know
i'm with the new cat you know
and
he
makes me feel better about myself
you know
there's a lot of people you know oh
you're pretty you're beautiful you know
nice body and i'm just like what are you
guys seeing i don't i don't see that
i don't know i don't know why i just
don't i don't i don't see that pretty
girl walking down the street i see
something wrong with me
it's gotta be something wrong with me
you know i don't have the highest
self-esteem
like everybody swears now and i do
it's just
you know i'm more non-tolerant you know
of a lot of things so it's harder for me
to find love because
i have a wall of
because of
so many past relationships that i
thought i was in love
you know
and it ended up
being
i was probably in love but the other
person wasn't
no
that's pretty much
how that boils down
but this new guy he makes me feel
good you know makes me
look at
things about myself a lot differently
you know
he's always telling me i don't know my
worth
you know and
i probably don't
i don't
you know
i don't feel worth too much
you know
i love me you know but at the same time
i don't
so
how are you going to find love when
you're not sure about how you love
yourself
i don't know
i'm caught in between
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
cherish your mother
cherish your mother
and when you have a chance
take it to the fullest
because you may not ever get another one
yeah
that's about it
all right quick fire
all right thank you so much for sharing
your
your life story
thank you for letting me get it off my
chest
really
it's interesting and beautiful
thanks
like you thanks
you